[Music]
when i'm night surfing the first thing i
really realize is how alone you are and
how quiet everything is
it's the most free spiritual thing you
could think of but once when you get a
wave it's incredible just to see the
colors come off the waves off the board
every time i look down when i'm night
surfing and i see that lit up board i go
my dad created this this is me my dad
[Music]
my name is sean johnson i'm a surfer and
a surf coach out of la and i started
surfing because of my dad
my dad would take me out he'd be surfing
i'd be boogie boarding in the white
water one day he's like you want to jump
on i'm like yeah let's go threw me on
the nose of a surfboard and
caught some waves i was like dad i want
to do this
so we'd be leaving the beach and also be
like look at that board in the trash can
and i'll be like yeah look at that board
of the trash can he goes no that's your
new board
[Applause]
i would get boards out of the trash at
malibu
bring him home strip all the fiberglass
off them get in there reshape the whole
board the way i thought sean would like
to ride it he would get out there and
test my prototypes and say you know i
really don't like this one or this one's
great kind of sucks for me that i don't
surf anymore but at the same time when
i'm shaping these boards i feel like i'm
surfing
he does it all by hand and that's the
part that makes me enjoy surfing them so
much because i know how much love and
how much hearts put into these boards
[Music]
in l.a the surfing is really crowded you
know i always thought man it'd be great
to surf at night but it's kind of scary
out there tonight i figured why not put
some leds on a board to where you can
just get out there and surf as long as
you want without the crowds
as far as i know my dad's the only one
making led surfboards in the united
states
maybe once a month when there's a full
moon we go night surfing we cruise down
to the beach
and it's just like old times when we go
surfing but now we're sharing it at
night time and he gets to enjoy me
surfing something he created and i get
to enjoy riding something he made
game time boys
the best thing about night surfing is
you get out there it's quiet
it's kind of mysterious my biggest fear
is maybe falling knocking my head and
getting knocked out and no one being
able to find me so the cool part with
having those led light boards attached
to you
you can kind of always be found or
spotted
[Music]
i think people are absolutely amazed
when they see the light boards at
nighttime
what are these flying light things in
the ocean right now
i feel like i'm an alien
freaking flying on a huge spaceship
surfing's really a bond between sean and
i i mean
you know it's just so much fun watching
them out there surf you know now that i
can't be out there with them surfing
seeing out there in the water tearing
these boards up makes you thoroughly
really proud
i couldn't surf let alone surf on my
dad's surfboards i don't know what i
would do it reminds me of why i fell in
love with surfing so much
[Music]
you